só 20 de hoje vou ensinar a fazer uma
santana do papel com o sport o lateral
para cinco balas
esse projeto é mais simples em
comparação com os outros e fazer um
projeto mais simples jogo mais
complicado porque se não quebra a toda a
gente quer fazer um deles e pronto
depois vocês fizerem a só roubar uma
bola que eles podem deixar a máquina
para trás mas antes de usar claro vocês
têm que usar proteção nem para os olhos
têm que ser responsáveis e vocês não
fumarem ou ter muita força para explorar
e depois volta atrás de nós e só
comprova que não fumem
então agora o trio não primeiro teste
tutorial assim passa estou aqui
então bora lá psol o primeiro tem que
rolar uma folha como se fosse uma rifa
que ela das freiras
caso vocês não conseguimos lá ela
direito e vou deixar um link na
descrição onde ensina a fazer a fifa
pasta passa depois errou e não foi a
volta de modo a fazer um tubinho dá
enfoque ajusta em tudo e prenda com fita
em várias partes para não ser lá depois
para finalizar o tubinho é no pedaço bem
grande passo de um lado a outro e collor
ii precisar de três domingos tive uma
rifa
nesta partida o cortar segmentos de
cinco centímetros para fazer empunhadura
da água colin o primeiro segmento nos
der mais jeito pressiona contra a mesa
pra ficar tudo certinho e vinculando os
outros segmentos
estou acumulado maneira de frente já que
o primeiro segmento fica ligeiramente
mais à frente do que fica embaixo vou
fazer sempre isso até chegar ao final
quem vai ficar mais por cento com
empunhadura de uma arma verdadeira como
estava por exemplo
agora vai ficar mais resistente e hoje
está aí uma rifa e controle ea volta dá
para agradar arma da empreendedora vai
dar uma assistência extra
vocês podem verificar depois quando
fizer pois a prefeitura volta é só ir
colando pedaço a pedaço
não ponho colo da volta e tenta vincular
uma vez porque é um caso complicado com
do seguro popular mas não podia se
insurjam popular assim até chegar ao
final e agora vou cortar para fazer a
parte dos portos balas e só depender das
bolas que vocês usarem usaram balas
maior tem que fazer os descendentes
maiores seja o presente só sei que usar
embalagens em vidro de fazer essas
coisinhas com 3cm ou seja terem dois
centímetros do total de votos bola
estiver em sites vão cortar isso com 400
modo kerbala de quem para fora do
treinamento seja fácil de retirar e por
atirar ok
é só você escolar enquanto der mais
jeito
agora as balas são marcar 400 no lado 3
outro lado a parte maior parte menor no
final é só aprender com fita para ter
uma melhor precisão eo que sentem um
vazio porque é um pouco complicado né
admirar porque na boca é bastante
simples e até barato laser foi bom então
é só encaixar ali na frente no cano e
pronto
já os bairros ficam ligeiramente para
fora você faz alterar como ele sabe que
ele vinha ao fim
agora quem mais aos testes com o
capacete é muito conhecido que o
treinamento é importante deixar alguns
projectos que se vocês quiserem ver mais
darmos do papel
é isso não chegamos ao fim e as partes
do estado se vocês quiserem ajudar o
canal é só deixar um vai se inscrevam
caso não sejam inscritos e deixem mais
sugestões de projetos que fazem porque
vocês pede é isso então vá até a próxima
só